hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now we're back in the middle of the
expert levels and I know it's gonna get
a lot harder I know that I'm going to
not have a good time with this actually
I'm gonna have a wonderful time with
this I'm not worried about having fun
what I am worried about is losing my
goddamn mind before I get to the end and
hopefully rescue Princess Peach because
I got 64 lives left and oh hi oh I
didn't know I wasn't ready yeah I was
too distracted by the fact that there
was a giant Bowser standing in the
middle of nothingness alright I just got
a run hop thank you
oh why why would you do this I'm not
good about being careful hat Oh am I
just Oh No let me let me put this a
little tonight yeah I probably didn't
put that where I needed to yeah okay oh
you have got to be yanking on some [ __ ]
oh this is going to be a [ __ ] how is
this dissing the expert levels this
better be the only challenging part
about it it better get real easy real
soon hey yeah okay well that's not where
I huh
oh man oh ha ha I wasn't even looking
out for that one I was trying to go
hoping the other ones oh this is going
to be a nightmare of epic proportions
but as is my life in Mario maker this is
what I've been subjected to this is what
you guys asked for you thought it was
too easy on the other levels that I was
getting away with I almost thought that
I got away with him wasn't for those
darn meddling kids okay
oh no I thought I was fast but it turns
out I'm dead okay I'm pretty sure if I
just get past that part that's gonna be
like the choke point of all this because
the rest of this it's just about being
slow and cautious and slow and cautious
isn't exactly in my job description but
Oh what he didn't you jump off of that
I'm not the best at the wall jump oh
this is where it all gets lost is where
it all gets lost level 10 I've still got
six more to go after this okay getting
pretty confident about that part I'm
gonna get cocky suit ah okay who just
chew oh that's that's the not good huh
huh why why wouldn't your job I push the
button oh man do I not need to hold down
why could I just could I just jump
without the Y button because the Y
buttons the run button the run faster
button and I don't think I need it when
I'm going up there but like okay like I
said I was gonna get rushing and then I
was gonna get cautious my hair is still
wet cuz I just popped out a shower but
you guys don't care about that that has
nothing to do with how I'm doing and
Mario maker god dammit stop rushing
fudgesicles why why
Easy's why didn't you jump huh No
well jump on the last one damn it ah
what the [ __ ] just god damn it just just
why wouldn't it jump on the last one
yeah I got that unlock ok so just run
forward where once yeah there we go
there we go yes please be the end
is it the oh I feel like that's a trick
I can get out of there right yeah I can
I can get out of this
oh no oh god damn it it was the traffic
oh oh son of a [ __ ] ok now don't go by
the super distracting yay and whoa woo
all right so what do we got now
hopefully it's easy street from now on
hello okay is this a choice if you Frick
me over with a bad choice here where am
I you son of a [ __ ] it's a random
choice are you kidding me are you
freaking yanking my dong oh my god
you are a giant giant hole in the ground
filled with dicks I don't even know what
what circumstances that would be but
that's what you are developer this level
[ __ ] God stupid mistake stupid stupid
stupid
no I know come on you can't [ __ ] me over
like that oh this is such [ __ ] god
damn it why did I have to get this level
why oh why did I have to get this level
why is this my randomly assigned level
why no ashen woof okay so what is with
this ledge here am I just supposed to is
it is it like all of them are a trick
cuz I would believe that aha maybe the
oh well that doesn't look good
alright let's see what happens oh okay
oh god damn it you sack crap ah hahahaha
all the way there all the way there and
I'm cut off by that Ditka tree what a
piece of [ __ ] no nope no no oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh wow what the [ __ ] is
going on
oh [ __ ] you okay just gotta get past
this part
no you can go too high 28 28 28 are you
kidding me
it's like he saves the touchiest no no
thank you for not panicking me
you're welcome me why don't you just do
it right the next time
oh no I won't don't worry about that
No Oh oh man walking into it why are
there no deaths over there we why are
there no deaths over there
that's a good question why are there no
X arrows over there that it seems to me
like that's where all of the arrows
would be right all of the marks would be
all the more all of my deaths are over
there yeah that's sure okay just just
because this is regard damn dick ulis I
want to see where these other pipes lead
if they're just so happens to be
something here or if it's just nothing
it's it's it's just nothing it's it's
those Wow holy crap twenty I have 20
lives left I have 20 lives left 20 yes
it's not like I expected this to be easy
I didn't I'm no fool no no no why I'm
sorry everybody
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I'm sorry
it just feels such I feel like such a
disappointment to everybody out there I
feel like I'm just failing you all
individually and you're all just like
you're not mad at me you're just you're
just disappointed and it's like well you
know we had high hopes for you Mikey
went into this you were more than
halfway done with these and you had you
know over half the lives you required so
we didn't see how this could go wrong
little did you know little ol Marquis mu
was ready to [ __ ] out another turd and
turns a game play Oh
I didn't even get to the spin I didn't
even get the first jumped right
Oh No
that is douchiness beyond douchiness i
beat this don't [ __ ] it no I'm not no no
I beat this [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm down to 12 lives god damn
it why aah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
who put a super expert level it what are
you oh god damn it
Oh what is that not but it's supposed to
be goddamn it
Oh oh great what is this what do
something okay
this is cool I'm happy about this I'm
happy about this new level than I'm on
what am i doing please tell me this just
rides me all the way down because no one
have to do thank you thank you for the
look of confidence Mario I'm not too
happy about it either
well this looks fun I really hope this
just hey please whoa whoa hello
why's this here okay whatever so long as
it's just it this better just be okay
oh I know what needs to happen whoa what
are you whoa what okay well he was just
gonna charge and me that's something
Bowser's never really done before what a
load of ass but just get me through this
goddamn level so that I can get on with
my goddamn life and then go back to
doing something stupid no no what the
[ __ ] you got to be [ __ ] with me
you've got to be [ __ ] kidding me oh
my god that's such a stupid thing why
it's so apparently there is a power up
here don't don't don't
no why is he over here [ __ ] you
okay just keep backing up or something I
don't know what you're doing
oh god no no oh my god how did I get out
of that I don't even know dude well okay
I gotta get him to shoot fireballs at
the other way but he's just he's being a
royal dick right now King Koopa the oh
really
[ __ ] it's even worse well that sounded
like something blowing up no what are
you kidding me well I found the secret
oh my god are you kidding me
I don't have these life is too loose
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] that's
all what a goddamn [ __ ] these
developers what [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
where was that secret give give to me
there we go I got it now well this is
good
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no well well this is
good enough you know what I'll take it
where is it there it is
pepper [ __ ] well lost it anyway y'all
[ __ ] you god damn it are you kidding me
no no god no oh don't be like this just
let me go by you are you kidding me
uh-huh just let me go by are you kidding
me why won't he
ah okay [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah Oh suck
dong oh man so anyway thank you all so
much for watching Mario maker this
episode has been I've been reading it
for 40 I never I'm gonna fail the hunger
Mario challenge I am there's no way such
such [ __ ]
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video give me some words of
encouragement the kind of you better not
kill me right off the bat you better not
you better not if you do I will see you
in the next video I am broken inside
Naza always we'll see you next week bye
bye
are you okay we guessed know
what's that you're holding hey you hey
you [ __ ] you get back here